MAN: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's been great.
MALE SPEAKER: The
event's fantastic.
We're really excited to have all
the Chinese developers attend.
MAN: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: I mean,
it's been really fun.
It's my first time
in Shanghai, and it's
been great to meet all
the developers here.
The energy has been
really astounding.
It looks like the content
is really relevant.
I can tell there's a
really high interest
for a lot of developers
and companies
wanting to build
businesses globally.
I love the ambition, and we're
really excited to be here.
MALE SPEAKER: The
offerings, the APIs
that Google has available
to build into your app,
and then generate revenue,
and then receive a payment
into a Chinese bank account.
So we're really
excited that we've
opened up the doors
to new opportunity
for Chinese developers to
access a global audience.
MALE SPEAKER: Hello.
This is Adam from Hong Kong.
We are from GDG group.
We are in Shanghai today in
Google Play Playtime event.
We have learned a lot of
stuff from the Google experts.
They taught us about
the newest development
for Google Play
Store and how can
we develop better
games and applications
for putting on the market.
So they gave us a
lot of statistics
and then some training so
that we can know what to do
and what to create.
I have met three teams that
we can work something out
together.
The event is so good.